my six survivors traveled from Iraq to
the H to make an emotional plea for
justice in a Dutch court giving names
and faces to the civilians killed on the
night of June the 2nd
2015 when an explosion destroyed not
only a weapons Factory run by isil but
also a densely populated
neighborhood abdalah Rashid s lost seven
members of his family including five of
his children he tried to save his
14-year-old daughter y
mama I told her everyone was fine
although they all died she asked me to
give her a hug I want to smell you one
last time she said and I huged her she
was fighting for her life but I could
not save
her he wants an apology and compensation
from the Dutch state which denies
accountability for the first time time a
court will have to decide on the
legality of air strikes conducted by the
International Coalition against isil the
verdict will not only provide long
awaited answers to Iraqi families but
could also serve as a signal to other
countries conducting air strikes causing
civilian casualties I mean if you just
currently look at Gaza so many people
without a voice without a face and so
many illegitimate
bombings there should Al always be
Justice someone should assess this
because otherwise it's just anything
goes I mean military can do whatever
they want the Dutch government says it
regrets the suffering of Iraqi civilians
affected by the bombardment but at the
hearing its lawyers called the attack
legitimate a verdict is expected later
this year step fast in Al jazer
the make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer